welcome to this video playing Ricky kids
Ricky kits Maxim Lagarde's not about
Shelikof Maxine regard ok um 93 how do
you actually prevent the French now I
guess you don't put d 4 is X invites the
French anyway yeah irritated me with
that ok so regular Stein it's French
quick 92
mm yeah this is very quickly played this
in fact is a slightly weird mix of
systems with the bishop III 92 an age
form okay I'm trying to make use of this
weakness on be too yeah not a move that
he probably loves to play ok so I'm
going to give this check or not I can
also play of six opening up the center
one problem is that this Bishop only
three is an unprotected piece okay no
it's not unprotected anymore but still
I'm going to break break em in the
center now Wow
very very interesting decision you know
maybe you really needed to do that
already but how to play that now
there's more than one good good idea but
I think it says I should try to do
something against the King the king is
some potentially vulnerable and they
need to get the bishop of course into
play yeah no GF I ever so slightly
slightly problematic
I know the default was probably bad bad
timing not not necessarily a bad concept
may be bad timing I know it's got to get
a good position for this is bloody
bishop no yeah I shouldn't shouldn't
have allowed that okay let's just hope
he cannot second age 7 immediately
probably not
now is playing very quickly
not quite sure why III was such a great
idea um ok question is not about 94 94
33 it be as this Queen d3 move which is
some problem or capture 23 candle stuff
but at least as weakens the light
squares enormously but it can play Queen
d3 now and just attack aged 70 km 93
that's not not so clear let's see the
main problem is not the position anyway
but the time with the sky a maximal oh
god I forgot I had to look earlier okay
so what is going to do bishop age 70 AD
I'm flicking a jade yeah all that one
both them make sense but this is
probably the better idea Jack attending
night F for the right moment it's a
better of timing we prevented that they
give this chick and then follow up with
bishop okay i only have from one minute
left follow up with Bureau B 5
I need to just take it is just dashing
out quick moves not considering much I
think at least okay so what now I can
just take Chang with the check shouldn't
be too bad
it's not a bad counter take him not paid
at all yeah it should be five would be a
very nice but he's got it protected mhm
just decided to attack the rock first
and then think for them okay so this
this night should I move it yeah I
probably need to question is if i go
here or why should i go not easy we came
speed up
maybe this even look for in the position
she takes neither for winning the Queen
could be could be a fun fun fun trick
okay come on let's do that I only have
40 seconds left if you move the knight
on d4 some point once to or you can go
here night f5 desperate be five yeah I'm
putting the Queen now four for some
don't know small stuff check Queen c2 is
the team check
check-check
time chain 15 seconds John Chang shoes
check position is relatively easy win
check check check check check check mate
all right I made it at the end yeah
impossible to tell what was happening in
this middle game just utter chaos the
main problem the whole time was that I
had burned so much time already on so
the position i think was was pretty
decent around him yeah computers is
already giving this as a win for black
or jam ok even with deform and now queen
bee fry consider this briefly but it
looked a bit strange to get the Queen's
off I cannot really take Queen before
would have been an interesting idea and
now I don't know it's it gets really
tricky night before this is a good move
night before now to make sure the bishop
on d3 is not a problem here yeah even
this has given us better for black
virgin truckee a3 is bad down not Bishop
b5
yeah well this is debatable but it seems
to be okay like this there hope check
computer's giving me a slight edge here
but okay this is just a crapshoot and
with this time check nobody going to be
able to really figure out what's going
on now g4s even the right one no Bishop
before yeah no chance but it's nice and
look at four is really the winning move
yeah that's good yeah I mean the idea i
saw a bit further but it looks a bit bit
bit scary yeah but it's winning is
winning that the night is hanging and if
you move it and down yeah this this
really needs to a winning but should be
fine quite funny and there's no meteor
despite all those pieces near the king
yeah so an interesting game i hope you
liked it with a bit funny thanks for
watching